hello
thank you for joining us for this
special live session of science news now
on what it's like for journalists to
cover the biggest story of our lives the
coronavirus pandemic
we'll be talking about the challenges of
covering this huge story while also
living through it
and we'll be answering audience
questions
so please ask them in the q a chat
section
i'm thrilled to introduce you to the six
amazing teams journalists who have led
our coverage of the pandemics
i'll let them introduce themselves amy
let's start with you
hi i'm amy cunningham i cover health and
biomedicine
i've written about
kids in covid and kobe vaccines among
other stories and this past year
i just finished a large project that
takes a historical look at infectious
diseases and epidemics over the past
century
i'm erin garcia de jesus i am a staff
writer here and i have mainly been
covering
viral viral variants i have a background
in evolutionary virology so i've been
writing a lot about the viruses
evolution as well as vaccines
and how
variants and vaccines are interacting
i'm john lambert i'm also a staff writer
here at science news and i focus more on
the public health side of the pandemic
so early on that was
covering a lot about testing and contact
tracing
and these days i've been focused a lot
on vaccine equity both in the us and
abroad
hi i'm laura sanders the neuroscience
reporter at science news
i've been focusing on the brain and how
the virus might or might not affect the
brain directly
and how stress from the pandemic has
interfered with all sorts of things
i've also covered how shutdowns and
school closures affected kids both
mental health
and academic performance
hi i'm sujata gupta i'm the social
sciences writer
and i've covered
a range of things involving people's
psychology and mental health behavior
risk perception
along with disparities
social and educational level disparities
hi i'm tina hesman say i'm one of the
senior writers here at science news
my beat is molecular biology the past
two years i've been covering mainly
many aspects of cobid
including
drug treatments
vaccines
how the virus affects the body
and
lots of
other little things like that
thank you all um let's start with aaron
and talking about the big news this week
you just reported on the new omicron
variant in our coronavirus update
newsletter and also for our website
and what it's been like covering the
emergence of these new variants
especially when
at the beginning there's almost no
information available
i mean in short it has been much like
the rest of this pandemic which is to
say it is a roller coaster
specifically with omicron i think
many of the unknowns
are
very much still unknowns
for instance when i was reporting on
things like the alpha variant that at
first emerged in the united kingdom at
the end of last year or
um
the beta variant there was some
indication already in the community of
increased transmissibility
um there is some indication that omicron
may be more
transmissible but a lot of that data is
very very early so i would say the
unknowns are even greater in this case
so we're navigating this very
hard to navigate time and it's it's very
hard to report on things that we don't
have answers for because people want
answers i want to know all the answers
to these questions our readers want to
know the scientists themselves want to
know but we
just don't have the data yet so trying
to take a step back
thinking about
why we don't have answers yet what will
it take to get answers has been an
interesting experience
and difficult i would say
really difficult that uncertainty and
frustration and just not knowing
uh feels a lot like it did way back in
january 2020 at the very beginning of
the pandemic
there was just so much we didn't know
john you wrote our very first story on
the novel coronavirus in early january
what were you thinking about that then
yeah um that week so i think i published
the story on january 10th
and that week my head was not in the
world of viral virology i had
was working on this story about fish
ocean acidification whether it was
affecting um fish behavior
and we get this who report that there's
this outbreak of a mysterious
pneumonia-like illness in wuhan
and i was assigned it not out of any
particular expertise in uh virology or
epidemics
and
i remember just trying to
to call up a few sources and try to get
a handle on
on what this was and what it meant and
going back reading the story now is kind
of surreal um i i have it up here and i
just want to read the first two
sentences because i think it's
kind of uh
crazy to think how little we knew um
but on january 10th in 2020 i wrote a
mysterious outbreak of pneumonia in
central china has preliminarily been
pegs to a new coronavirus but the world
health organization says there's no need
to panic chinese officials have reported
little evidence so far of human to human
transmission the who says making an
epidemic less likely
which in hindsight seems kind of uh
crazy that that that that was our our
take back in early january but um
so to sum up i wasn't really thinking
that it would explode into what it has
uh when i first started reporting
reporting on it back then
was there one
piece of evidence or thing you heard
that made you realize oh gosh this could
be really bad
yeah i think um
i think as
as sort of the weeks progressed and the
sources i was talking to
went from being sort of very careful not
to overstate the risk to being
a little more sort of audibly worried um
my general sense of worry sort of
crept up uh
and then there was actually a study that
tina flagged about a german business
meeting where it became clear that um
people could spread
the virus before symptoms so tina was
you know with the person who made me
think oh gosh
this is something we
uh
will probably be having to deal with for
quite a while right yeah that's
that study uh out of germany was at this
um german auto parts company
where they really jumped on things and
that outbreak at that company told us so
many things about the virus
that was like the thing for me that that
really made it
seem
like a big deal and that this thing was
to go crazy
because
they did find evidence
of
a transmission before people had
symptoms and
in a follow up to that initial
paper
they like actually tracked the people
and they isolated infectious virus from
them and they found that even people who
never developed symptoms
could
transmit the virus or or at least they
were they were making infectious viruses
and then a little later
at the beginning of april
the
the um
national academies of sciences released
a report
saying that
the the coronavirus
is airborne that it could be transmitted
in aerosol droplets that
you spew out just
sitting there breathing or quietly
talking and then you make many more
uh after that so
those two things together were like
oh wow this this could be bad
yeah oh wow indeed and laura you were
actually at a scientific meeting
with thousands of other scientists
uh what was that like
yeah i mean looking back
i would never have guessed what would
have happened next um but it was very
much a moment that i'll never forget i
was in a a session on the coronavirus
8 a.m on valentine's day
with my editor making more house and we
were listening to trevor bedford at the
hutch and
a scientist from dates foundation talk
about
how much we don't know about the virus
and how our estimates at the time were
likely to be
vast vast underestimates of how many
people had already been infected even
back in february
and so yeah just that feeling of sitting
in a room with a lot of other people
inside in a big conference
and there was a sense of kind of anxiety
and
a fear really um it was the first time
that it really hit home with what we're
facing what we're looking at um so yeah
that's a that's a moment i won't forget
from this pandemic
yeah and it's not often when we're
sitting covering a scientific meaning
whereas a dominant emotion is fear
that's for sure
uh oh we have an audience question
um
how do you handle stories
where the information you're learning
today
means that a story that was written only
a few months ago is now inaccurate i
think that one that we saw a lot of this
because
especially in the early months there was
so much science coming out so fast and
things are changing so fast
so who wants to talk about how we as
journalists answer that
well i think
we try to acknowledge
what the state of the knowledge was
before
and what the scientists have now
done in order to figure out
what is really the case or at least what
is our best understanding now
and
you know communicating that uncertainty
is
is really important and it's a very
difficult job
i think we
we need to
to let people in on
what exactly the scientific process is
that it builds on itself it corrects
itself
and
you know just because the state of the
knowledge changes doesn't mean that
you know
that means we have to throw out
everything and can't trust anything
um
over time
you get a more concrete understanding of
the thing
and
once you build up a certain level of
evidence
you can be pretty confident in the
answer
but
you know sometimes mistakes are made and
you know i remember
at the very beginning before we knew
that this was an airborne virus
people thought that it was transmitted
mainly by droplets that you would spew
out and then you know touch a surface
and touch your face
and and then get infected that way
and they were saying don't wear masks
and
so
uh
one of my husband's
co-workers
his wife called me
and was like
you know i bought masks now people are
saying we shouldn't wear masks
but they're saying we need them for the
hospital workers but if they protect the
hospital workers why won't they protect
me
and i thought you know what that's a
really
good question
and
i
i don't know what to tell you
and i
you know i i i still regret from
the very beginning saying that
you know ordinary people shouldn't wear
masks because it's very clear
that masks work and are one layer of
protection against the virus
and you just have to
own any mistakes
and like i said
you know acknowledge what the state of
the
knowledge was before
and
try to move on
thanks tina yeah it's it's so
again this has been such a difficult
subject for us to cover in so many ways
um actually here's another audience
question that is a good one for us this
this
listener says he's a print journalist
and he's very impressed
with the academic credentials of the
journalists who write for science news
since many of you have phds
and
other advanced degrees
and
how do you
how does that academic knowledge change
how you approach your assignments
i mean i think for me it doesn't
always affect how i approach assignments
i do sometimes have to kind of remove
myself from what i know just on a
regular basis um
to think about what our readers need to
know because my background is in
virology and my background is in
immunology and i write a lot about both
of those topics and so sometimes
i have to remember that something that
isn't you know that is buried in my
brain that i know as
something that i think lots of people
will know you know like t cells are
important not everybody knows what a t
cell is um you know these are cells that
are in our body that
are on the hunt for
pathogens that are going to protect us
and you know they're really important
for protecting us from uh disease and so
taking a step back and thinking about
what information is 100 relevant to what
story i'm writing and what do our
readers questions are our reader is
going to have
is really important
thank you aaron that's really helpful
especially for people like me who do not
have phds in virology so
um i want to ask amy a question
especially since she covered a lot of
how
kobe has impacted children including
you know how how they get sick with
profit what might happen and also how
it's
affected
schools and learning
and how how is that
being reporting on that shaped your
perception of how this is affecting
people
yeah so
you know
going back to what tina is saying our
understanding of this virus continues to
change
over the course of the pandemic and
as a reporter we're taking in all that
information and we're continually trying
to
make a bigger picture
but
often the public just gets snapshots and
i think it's been
you know it can be difficult to
um
dislodge early impressions
uh
that people get you know before we more
data has come in and before we have
gotten to get that bigger picture and
this has been really true with kids in
covid so you know early on
there were fewer cases for kids compared
with adults and it wasn't clear if kids
could really spread coveted
and that's in contrast to you know we
know kids are really good spreaders of
influenza
um
but
you know that was a time when kids
weren't in school and that was a time
when kids were in the community like
they normally are so there's a lot of
nuance there and there's a lot more we
had to learn but i think early on this
this idea got stuck in people's heads
that oh kids aren't affected by this and
that's a comforting thing it's
understandable why people
heard that and like okay good we're set
with that um but you know we found that
wasn't the case
as kids got back to school as kids got
back to their activities to their sports
as they were out and about as especially
as the delta variant hit
cases and kids went up and with that
came more hospitalizations and we
thought came more deaths and
we have you know learned about a really
severe immune response that kids can
have
weeks after infection
we've learned kids can have long covered
um
so i think it's really challenging as a
reporter you know
all this information is coming in and
you're trying to create this bigger
picture that captures the nuance and
like tries to help people understand you
know this is what we understood in the
beginning but this is where things are
now
and that's you know for many things
about this pandemic that that has been
a challenge to
get out
thank you amy uh we have a listener who
wants to know about
what process we use to verify
stories before we print them
and also you know what we use as
resources and that's that's actually
something we've talked a lot about a lot
about with this because
um
we ended up using a lot of sources that
we typically don't rely on we're pretty
much obsessed with accuracy here at
science news and
you know we fact check we have
professional fact checkers we do um a
lot of verification and are very careful
about our sources but
uh this upended our processes in a lot
of ways um tina you had some thoughts on
that you want to weigh in
yeah um definitely i've
i've been reporting a lot on vaccines
and drugs and a lot of the first
information about those comes from press
releases from the companies that are
making them
and so you have very little data to go
on you have only the numbers that they
give you and they don't tell you much at
all sometimes they don't even tell you
exactly how many people
were in the trial for instance
so
you have to
report that you you put a link to the
source
um and then you talk to other experts
and try to see you know does this sound
reasonable what are the caveats here
um
and that's also been true for preprints
so
you know prior to this we rarely would
report on preprints which are
papers that are posted to these internet
servers for anybody to look at and
comment on
that have not been
through the peer review process that is
that is normal before papers appear in
scientific journals
where
where other experts in the field have
combed through the data and and seeing
whether this is a a reasonable
thing
you know peer review is
lots of papers that get retracted even
after they've gone through peer review
but at least it's
it's one layer
of um
vetting of of a scientific study
that you don't have
when it's a pre-print so you have to be
really diligent
about
going and getting outside comment and
and getting people
to who who really do know what's going
on in that field to take a look at it
and and try to help you out um
tell you where they're shortcomings and
things like that
um
yeah we do a lot of
a lot of fact checking
um
you know trying to find independent
sources to to verify these things is
really not easy especially when there's
so much information coming out
and so much of it being contradictory
you don't really know exactly
what is right at the beginning and like
i said earlier you
sometimes it's
it's maybe better to wait a little while
to try and figure out
what
what's really true and what's not by the
weight of the evidence that's coming in
yeah i just wanted to add something to
that is that tina you know mentioned
that we're relying a lot on pre-prints
which we are but we also have to
remember that sometimes even
peer-reviewed papers we really need to
get a lot of perspective on those as
well because peer review is not perfect
and so getting a lot of talking to a lot
of scientists or talking to a lot of
experts in that field to get a sense of
even peer-reviewed papers is really
important i remember
the first coronavirus story that i wrote
was
you know a few weeks after john wrote
his and it was a peer-reviewed paper
that said that the origin of the
coronavirus was in snakes and
all the virologists that i knew were
like this is ridiculous no and i knew as
a virologist that it was probably also
not true so i talked to a few experts
and who told me
the analysis that was in this paper is
not appropriate for the type of
conclusions that they're trying to come
to so
we i'm taking this with a very you know
as a grain of salt this is probably not
the case and ultimately it definitely
was not the case um
it was an interesting experience and
that means that being my first story was
you know taking down a peer-reviewed
paper was
interesting
yeah
two um i think science news has uh
provided a good
a good resource in this media
environment where often
[Music]
headlines will sort of grab something
really catchy from an individual study
but when you delve into the details of
that study
it doesn't really support the headline
that's getting sort of blasted across a
lot of um
large outlets one
example that i remember was in
it was in
august of 2020 or sometime around then
there was a study that
caused headlines to say that neck
gaitors were worse than wearing no mask
at all because they like sheared the
droplets as they were coming out of your
out of your mouth
and a lot of people wear neck gators as
masks um and so
i looked into the details of that paper
and it was in no way designed to answer
that question um and i think that we
provided a good
uh a good kind of check on
this story that had gotten
uh or this paper that had gotten
sort of undue coverage by just
delving into the details of that paper
and saying what they can and can't say
yeah i particularly appreciated your
work on that john because it is it's
it's painstaking reporting and it's also
tough to come back when all these other
news outlets are saying oh yeah neck
gators are bad and say well no actually
once the study says exist
and
make sure that people get the accurate
information
we have a number of listeners who are
curious about
covet in the brain
and i'd love to hear from laura dujaka
because you have
put a great deal of work
looking at you know covert effects from
the brain on mental health and also on
how
people behave laura do you want to start
out
yeah sure it's it's been fascinating um
and like all these other aspects of the
pandemic the science has been
really unsettled there are still a lot
more questions than answers
um the
the kind of best evidence so far
suggests that co the coronavirus doesn't
affect
infect brain cells directly but it's
more
kind of the systemic effects of
of being severely ill um
but one thing that's definitely clear is
the stress and worry and anxiety that
this has all caused has huge effects um
and it's been interesting because that's
not a new area of neuroscience you know
for a long time people have known that
severe long
unpredictable stress can really do a
number on all sorts of things our our
thinking abilities our sleep our mental
health
um so we've been kind of following along
and trying to
put what we're all experiencing into
this context of this research that we
know
so it's been it's been interesting
thinking about you know the features of
the pandemic such as we're all isolated
at home we're all wondering what's going
to happen next it feels like a roller
coaster as erin said
um and and you know added burdens of
homeschooling children or extra job
duties it's all kind of this perfect
storm of if you were to design a system
to create kind of damaging stress
responses this would be it
so i mean that's a that's the
pessimistic answer i think adam might
have more
more optimistic you know what can we do
about it um
how do we go from here
um
well i'll start with pessimism but maybe
i can end with optimism
so i remember when i was first studying
sort of the mental health fallout of the
pandemic there have been no books
written on how we would handle pandemics
and
there was this expectation that people
would behave in a certain way basically
they would follow whatever advice is
given um but the advice was as tina said
um kind of contradictory like around
mass and then also just people didn't
behave in ways that
that
people had predicted
um
and so covering behavior has been a very
interesting journey um through this
whole thing um
i just remember early on i covered um
i spoke to a scientist who talks about
risk perception a lot and she just has
this excellent point that
um we know that people who feel more
angry are more are going to flout the
rules more i think
and people who feel more fearful are
going to sort of hunker down more and
that turned out to be so prescient i
think in the end
um
and i think personally i was getting a
little
down like we were getting this
overall i would say we've gotten the
science of our understanding of this
virus pretty pretty solid like we kind
of know how it operates and we keep
trying to keep up with all these
variants but we haven't really done a
good job on the um
on the softer sciences i guess on the
behavior and the decision making and the
risk analysis like that's been a lot
muddier um
and so at some point i think i just took
a turn to psychology like what can
psychology say about how we can handle
all this noise um
and
uh i sort of it was it was a strange
route like i i was like well
i don't remember how it happened i was
reading about aristotle for some reason
and he has these sort of two ideas like
people
um pursue a good life through happiness
and these are lay terms or through
meaning and i knew that people weren't
really happy and then i'd also read a
paper that said that we get meaning sort
of through our routines and those were
really disrupted and i'm like oh great
so we're just not gonna have a good life
and then i came across a body of work
that
that really just spoke to me and it was
like novel experiences alone not adding
up to anything greater just doing new
things could maybe help us sort of
survive this moment
and so i started applying these things
to my own personal life i took a pottery
which i read about in one of my stories
um
and i started walking regularly with a
friend initially it felt so stupid we'd
go to the same
place on the same day and we'd go on the
same exact walk and like months into
this i'm like wow i this is really an
anchor point in my life so um
yeah i don't know if for me that was
like a more optimistic turn that like we
can do these things that can make our
lives a little bit better they're small
they may not be like
sustainable for like a good life for the
long haul but hopefully this is not
going to last forever so
that's kind of where i came away with
that
and laura and sujata you had a really
interesting conversation as part of our
session that was recorded on stress and
the brain and pandemic where you talk to
both a neuroscientist and also a
psychiatrist who works with a lot of
populations in different countries
people who have been in very stressful
traumatic situations
and
i loved looking at that both in terms of
brain and society and
how
we're so a part of our communities and
that that communities can actually help
us through these horrible times
what did you learn from that
conversation
yeah i mean it gets to this idea of
where we're social creatures we derive
so much of our meaning and our health
and our success and happiness from
those around us and being a part of a
community
um so there have been really well-known
effects of isolation you know in human
beings and in animal studies we're not
meant to be alone we need
we need stimulation we need other people
around us um
and so
i think
that that discussion and that framework
of
us as a part of a larger system is
really helpful and interesting both in
terms of kind of
how things go wrong but also how we can
use it to to buoy ourselves to to
support each other
and to heal a little bit
yeah i want to add to that oh sorry no
go ahead i was just gonna say that um
brandon court was the
researcher i spoke with and i had read a
popular science article where he talked
about ptsd and his research really
showed that we tend to treat ptsd or
post-traumatic stress disorder as a sort
of individual problem um manageable with
sort of wellness programs or yoga or
mindfulness which not to knock any of
that but his research really showed that
it's a societal problem that when um
people returning from war have a
societal support group they actually
fare a lot better than if they're left
on their own with all their sort of
wellness programs um and i thought that
was really eye-opening and just really
spoke to how intentional we need to be
in this moment where it's easy to be
super distant
that we need to continue to cultivate
our communities or build new communities
and actively seek out community as one
of the most important things for our our
overall well-being
so true and i also loved how your
researchers talked about empathy as
being incredibly powerful not just
receiving empathy which you should yeah
that'll make them feel better but also
having empathy for other people
as making yourself feel better too
one thing that i think has been hard for
us all
everyone around the world but also for
us as journalists is being stuck at home
working from
our houses and apartments and um
as journalists we love to be out in the
world and reporting on what's happening
and john you had the opportunity to do
some field reporting this summer on
getting vaccines out to underserved
communities what was that experience
like after being at home for so long
yeah it was really energizing um
so i had been
kind of thinking about doing a story um
on vaccine access around that time
in late spring and early summer
the
the sort of sense that i got was that in
general people kind of thought that like
the us was awash in vaccines and if you
weren't vaccinated that was sort of on
you um
when in fact
a lot of communities faced
a number of different kinds of barriers
in getting access
and i was interested in exploring that
question and a statistic
from a kaiser family foundation poll
popped out to me
from that time which found that hispanic
adults were
more than twice as likely or about twice
as likely to express
a strong desire to get the vaccine but
they hadn't yet gotten it than other
groups
and so i started doing some
some digging to try to figure out why
that might be the case um and ended up
talking to
a couple of medical professionals who
are
um who sort of started this
this entity called denito's covid
to try to
get vaccine to try to bring vaccines to
people where they were in
different hispanic communities around
philadelphia
and i talked to
two people involved on the phone and
they were really
great conversations um
this this small team was working sort of
over time on a volunteer basis uh for
the most part
uh
trying to get vaccines to these
communities and and setting up sort of
pop-up events at different community
events
um
where they could meet people who often
aren't sort of
going out of their way to get medical
care a lot of people in
or
some people in these communities were
undocumented and so they sort of go from
their home to work to a trusted place of
worship and that's sort of
the only places that they really go and
this this uh group was trying to bring
them
bring vaccines to where those people
were um and i was lucky enough to be
able to go to one of these events
uh and actually talk to
the people who had talked to the phone
on that the doctors and nurses involved
in in running these events
um in person and get to get sort of a
better sense for who they were and why
they were doing what they were doing
um and also talking to the people who
were at that event it happened to be a
sort of community soccer game where
there was live music and
taco stands and other food trucks
and just talking to them about why they
hadn't gotten vaccinated and why they
were getting vaccinated now
and it was really
it was really energizing to just hear
from from people in person
and i think it
created a better story because i was
able to get sort of a taste of
um
a taste of what that event was actually
like
yeah that that story
kind of inspired me too john because
it was like you know it's never too late
to get vaccinated and
one aspect that you didn't really
touch on here is that
a lot of people haven't gotten
vaccinated because of misinformation
and that's been a big theme also
throughout the pandemic is just a lot of
misinformation about the virus itself
about vaccines
about um
treatments
um
and so you know that's that's kind of
another big part of what we do as
journalists is trying to get people
accurate
information and
counteract that misinformation without
inadvertently spreading it which is kind
of a challenge
yeah we actually got a great question on
that from a listener who wanted to know
how does your awareness that you're
speaking to almost
two warring publics the coveted vaccine
deniers and the pro-vaccine encouragers
affect the content and tone of your
reports
and we write for the general public how
do you write for the public when you
know that people have vastly different
points of view about this
you know some some of that is kind of
hard to counteract because it's
it's a belief system
as as opposed to
um
presenting people with facts and and
and then having them decide rationally
based on the facts
but as journalists that's
kind of
what we do
and i recently wrote
a story and a newsletter that was
adapted into a story for our website
about misinformation surrounding
infertility from the vaccines
i got very frustrated because every time
infertility would come up
other outlets would say things like
there's no evidence that the vaccine
causes infertility
well while that's true it's not nearly
strong enough because
not only is there no evidence that it
causes infertility there is plenty of
evidence that it does not cause
infertility
and so i kind of went through a rundown
of various studies that show that it
does not cause infertility it does not
cause still burst it you know
it doesn't harm you
but getting covered actually does
i don't know if that changes anybody's
mind
but
it's what i can do to
to be part of a solution
rather than
part of the problem in spreading this
information
thank you tina um amy i'd like to ask
you a question you mentioned earlier
that you spent a lot of time this year
looking at
epidemics of the past as part of our
century of science coverage for our
centennial
and you really came to find that those
experiences that people had before
really have lessons for us now
what do you think is important for
people to know about that
um
yeah so
uh in working on this you know for all
of the advances that we've made in our
understanding of pathogens and
the immune system and
in the development of vaccines which is
all truly amazing
what really struck me as i looked back
at epidemics over the last century going
back to the 1918 influenza pandemic
is what hasn't changed
it hasn't changed nearly enough
um
epidemics continue to disproportionately
impact black people latino people
indigenous people and others
due to racial discrimination and
long-standing health inequities
epidemics can leave many children
parentless
and evidence shows that without societal
support
these children face devastating health
and socioeconomic consequences
epidemics
leave communities grieving
and yet society as a whole is
is in a real rush to put epidemics
behind us
in the end you know epidemics
it's not just a story about science it's
a story about people and about suffering
and about loss
and i think we need to do a much better
job
acknowledging that acknowledging the
grief that's out there acknowledging the
loss that people have experienced
understanding more about what does it
mean to
live through an epidemic what does it
mean to emerge from an epidemic what do
we need to do to support people
and
and take care of
the lingering
long-lasting physical and mental impacts
and it's also
really you know
we are still
the public health cornerstones that we
rely on with masking with social
physical distancing with uh
you know closing
closing down
large public uh venues
we started doing that a long long time
ago these things work for us and you
know they're really important parts of
our response
thank you amy um we've had a couple
questions from listeners who want to
know about
what it's like to be living through a
crisis at the same time reporting on it
and um was it a challenge to step away
from the anxieties you were facing
personally
to report on this issue
who would like to answer that one
i can start um
partly it's it's really hard for me to
disconnect from
anything
that's going on i think in part just
because even where i'm not a journalist
i would still be thinking about this
extensively um
i
because of my background a lot of the
people that i interact with on a regular
basis are in the virology world
so even when you know i'm not
at work thinking about viruses the
people that i talk to in my daily life
i'm also talking about viruses or
you know the immune system or my mom is
a school nurse like i'm talking to her
about what's happening in her school
um
so
i don't often get a break but then when
i try to force myself to take a break or
take a step back
i can't
um it
and you know especially in my classes
when i was in grad school uh you know we
hear a lot about we would talk a lot
about disease x you know we've talked
about pendant we would learn about
pandemics that have happened in the past
and you know what's the future one going
to look like and so
the realization that this is
you know
a disease x there will be other ones in
the future is
it's a surreal experience i think to
have gone through the training that i
did and then be living through this and
then reporting on it it's
sometimes i feel like
a little bit dissociated from everything
um and i think part of that is probably
defense mechanism so i don't
go too far down the path or i'm trying
to protect you know my own mental health
like
lauren sudrata alluded to you know all
of us are struggling
um
i don't know how long it's going to take
to for me to
really kind of grieve once all of this
is over um
it's a one day at a time type thing
yeah i hear you about that aaron about
being always on
because
when i'm not
reporting on stuff actively and reading
all these papers and
i'm you know i'm hearing the news
and then i have
family members and friends asking me
you know
for information
um and then for advice about what they
should do
in their daily lives i mean i have
friends on facebook who message me and
you know one was asking me
should i get my kid vaccinated right
away or should i wait for a while
and
other ones have
have asked me you know
various questions that they asked me to
to vet things that they see on facebook
or in in social media which is
is good i mean i'm i'm glad that they're
looking to see whether or not what
they're hearing is true
but it's
i feel a tremendous sense of
responsibility
to make sure that people have good
accurate
information and it can be really hard
when
you know i don't always know what to do
in my own life
so you know how can i possibly tell
someone else what to do
it's it's very difficult
um
so yeah it's it's
it's been a hard row
we all know too much
and too little at the same time right
right i mean and it also you know
intellectually
the more you learn about it like it's
right you know there's like interesting
things about it at the same time you're
also part of this
you're part of a pandemic where people
are dying people are sick
and
[Music]
you are trying to maintain
a kind of
i don't know you never know when it's
going to hit you how
sad this whole thing is right you're
trying to do your work and you're trying
to put information together and then
something can just strike you about how
devastating this has been
um
you know i would say for me some you
know i love it when people ask me
questions because that energizes me like
when i'm talking to other people people
are asking me
opinions about vaccines or
you know
talk asking me okay this new variant has
come like what do we know about how well
vaccines work um you know i love being
able to say
our immune systems are really good at
what they do we can trust in our immune
system and we can
you know believe that things are are
going to be okay at the end of the day
um
but at the same time you know then when
i sit down and i have to write the story
i just i feel the weight of everything
that i'm going to put on the page and
that people are going to read that and
sometimes it's a little bit
you know i freeze because like i don't
know how to put what i just told
somebody out loud into words on the page
um
that's a weird
weird experience
yeah and as the editor my job is to make
it possible for these wonderful
journalists to do their jobs and
you know when it's when it's a story
like this which is
such an important story and the
information that we're dealing with
depending on its accuracy could
save lives that could harm people
um
you know there is that huge
you know
i wish i could say all these wonderful
people it's okay fine you know go take a
long vacation and enjoy yourself but i
know that
they just it's
exhausting as it is they they don't
wanna they don't want to give up on this
story which is part of what makes them
as good as what they are but it's hard
it's hard
um and
on the other side of that the flip side
we've also talked
about what gives us hope and i know
sujata talked about her
explorations and finding meaning in life
both through new scientific research and
also through her pottery which
i thought was a wonderful way to combine
science and real life
um
what else gives you hope
john what gives you hope in the midst of
all this
um yeah uh
something that has
given me hope in my reporting um because
we we sort of talk to
and often rely on a lot of um the same
sources and you can kind of get a sense
for how tired they're getting as
as their scientists trying to
keep figuring this out um
and
or public so in my reporting i've talked
to a lot of
local public health officials whether
that be
like a city official who's trying to run
public health programs or
school nurses trying to set up
testing programs for their school
and
talking with them i always feel a bit
more hopeful
knowing that there are these people who
are
really working
working against uh incredible challenges
and often
amidst the public who
either sort of questions or outright
rejects what they're what they're trying
to do and sort of
the
um the work that they're doing
and
it's i mean it's it's really hard on
them and let's and yet a lot of the a
lot of the public health workers who
i've
spoken with over the course that this
pandemic just continue to kind of
do their best to build up a testing
program for their school or try to find
new and creative ways of reaching people
who haven't yet been vaccinated
[Music]
and it it gives me a little bit of hope
to know that there are people out there
like that who are
still plugging away against incredible
odds
yeah it gives me hope to know that there
are these amazing scientists out there
who are you know they're working on
vaccines they're working on treatment
they're working to better understand the
virus and what it does to our bodies and
how our immune systems react
and uh
and also just to see
something we touched on in the session
that aaron and i had earlier with uh
four code scientists
about how collaborative people have
gotten
i mean there are these huge
collaborations that have
hundreds if not thousands of scientists
from all over the world
you know putting their brain power to
solve these problems
and
it's amazing how much they have learned
in such a short time
it seems like it's never enough of
course but
you know just the fact that they're on
the job that's
that's very helpful for me
yeah i would say i kind of think of it
as great what i'm grateful for
i'm grateful for all the doctors and
medical practitioners who have been
caring for people throughout this also
starting off with almost no information
and very little they could do
except provide the care that you provide
for someone who has
is experiencing the symptoms you know um
and
i'm grateful as you know as john was
saying for all the public health
officials that have been working so hard
and i'm grateful for
vaccines that we
have something that can give our immune
systems a preview of a pathogen
something that can protect us from
the worst effects
is incredible and it's not something
that
we have for everything it's not
something we've had in the past
um
it's it's it's it's amazing and
expand on that last point amy it's just
that's also the thing that gives me hope
is that we
scientists developed a vaccine so
quickly thanks to decades of research
that has gone into all of this
well before the pandemic even began um
so you know all of that work that they
pulled on to make these vaccines within
a year is just mind-boggling and
sometimes i
i sit down and i think about where we
might be in the pandemic
if we did not have vaccines and it would
be a very very different place right now
i think i mean there's obviously a lot
of
hurdles that we're still trying to
overcome vaccine inequity vaccine
hesitancy um
you know just getting vaccines to people
who want them but can't get them i mean
those are big things that we have to
overcome but the fact that we even have
them in the first place to be having
those conversations
is incredible
yeah i was going to add that too it
didn't have to work out this well you
know it's
i'm
just so incredibly grateful and shocked
that it
worked as well that they're so
incredibly effective
i've had my little daughters get
vaccinated last weekend and it was just
this moment of
extreme gratitude
and more broadly i think what gives me
hope is this
famous and cheesy mr rogers line of look
for the helpers look for the helpers
here and that includes those scientists
that includes all our health care
workers that includes all of our
cafeteria workers who have been making
meals for kids who need them
that includes you guys covering all of
the science and and giving people the
the information we need so
yeah that's where i am
and teachers
let's throw them into are we going
having to
come back and
you know in a really uncertain
environment
as as there was the return to school
happened
thank you all there are those are
such
heartfelt reflections and i'm looking at
one more comment here from
a listener
um that says since we're celebrating 100
years of science news i would be
interested to see a retrospective of how
science and these journalists a hundred
years ago covered the last page of the
phases of spanish flu in 1921.
and i think that's a great question
and you can start by looking at amy's
wonderful story on our century of
science page which is looking at the big
scientific advances of the past hundred
years and also includes uh highlights of
our coverage
and you can also dig into the our
archives on our
sciencenews.org website which has
more than 80 000
uh
articles of original coverage which you
can see exactly what it looked like on
the page back then
and this spring we are going to also do
a history of our reporting over the
years
which includes some of the amazing
things in science that we've covered
whether it's you know the
discovery of the dna double helix or
insulin or antibiotics or the space race
but also
uh some places where we went wrong and
science went wrong too and covering
things that turned out to be
dangerous or long or unethical so i
encourage you to
stick with us and look forward we've got
a lot more coming as part of our
celebration
of our centennial
and i am hopeful and grateful because of
our great journalists and many others
around the country
um
we just had someone posted a comment
saying how wonderful it was that people
were able to move from physical to
virtual socialization and work
and soon concerts work school play dates
while providing social interaction
in new ways online that's true i think
at the time it didn't seem
like it would nearly the compensation
for not being together but i know that
um all that virtual communication last
winter really helped me get through this
and i know it did for many others so
um
i would like to say
thank you again to our amazing
journalists and the work they do and
thank you to our great audience and
science news readers online and in print
for
supporting us
and
um
anybody have a last comment you want to
say before we sign off
all right please stick with us and
um see what we do in our next hundred
years of science coverage
thank you all